I got a good view though, so jokes on you.
Oh, your dad?
Yeah, I get to see your feet.
Your dad's feet?
Jimmy, I worry about you.
Really?
Do you care?
I think you have zero survival instincts.
Zero, you know.
My little princess needs some man-wee muscles, I see.
Careful, princess.
Oh, they're beetles.
Oh, look, that's not as bad.
That's not as bad.
I like beetles.
I like...
Yeah, you had no face.
Did you see that?
He was balding, too.
Do you think he was just malding?
Maybe he watches us.
Oh, my God.
Wait.
Someone was having a good time.
It's time to learn how to tie a rope.
Well, I've been here before.
Oh, wait, wait.
What?
Do you remember anything about the gameplay?
No.
No, okay.
All right.
The only thing I remember is that we were, like, we were,
like, dripping off.
Oh, dude, I'm doing that right now.
What do you mean?
Hello, everyone.
And welcome to Little Nightmares 3.
On what platforms are we able to get, Little Nightmares 3,
Chibi?
Let's do a little test.
Was I supposed to read stuff?
Oh.
Hello little boy.
You want to see my collection?
Collection one.
Hit that.
There you go.
See, look at that.
Let's freaking go.
Teaching my child.
I saw you got close to the edge and I wanted to go further
than you.
Okay, wait there.
Wait there.
I'm coming back.
Teaching my child.
Basic problem solving.
Oh, yeah, I'll go second.
It's like I'm the main character of the story.
I got a good view though.
So jokes on you of your dad Yeah, I get to see your feet
Your dad's feet.
Okay, I'm gonna kill myself because I'm real I forgot as a
respectful adult I'll wait for you to go up before I go up
the ladder jump to the rope.
All right, I'm watching You did great Oh, wait, can we grab
it?
I don't know.
It looks like we can spin it or like attach something to it.
Thanks.
Wait, oh, maybe?
Hit it.
Oh, my God.
I knew I was so smart.
You spin me right around, baby, right around.
Like a rock, baby, right, right, right.
Ah, that's why you just stopped.
That's so messed up.
Why did you jump left?
You could have jumped to the right.
Why did you?
Jump to the right.
Chibi, I worry about you.
Really?
You do?
You care?
I think you have zero survival instincts.
What is that?
Did you hear that?
Yeah.
Okay, Chibi.
You see that rope in the center?
Yeah.
You know what to do.
Guys, we're figuring it out.
And look, now this should stay, right?
Yeah.
All right.
Oh, excuse me.
Oh, whoa.
Excuse me.
I need feather falling Oh, we're so strong Dude Look at us,
go This is unlike my wife Oh, there's the crow Oh, shoot
him, shoot him Shoot the crow It's time for exam, Mr.
Chicken Yay Let's eat him I don't think there's any much
meat on him left Also, isn't he like I feel like he's too
malnourished I don't think it's good meat for our bodies I
think he's dead, yeah, it's probably rotting Well, I mean
like all meat is technically dead meat but i just feel like
i mean he has great skin so i feel like it'll be not good
nutritious for us all right let's maybe they'll have like a
like a wendy's around here yeah maybe yeah wendy's for human
bodies that sounds like a good time all right oh my gosh did
you die did you die why did you do it every time you've
fallen you've never said anything
continuously oh my god wiki's alive five eleven versus six
foot that's right you are a little careful princess i see
that there you go princess needs uh some man we muscles i
see careful princess oh oh and jump jump jump jump use the
use the power of gravity oh oh it's okay oh oh my god we
finally learned how to run oh we did it Go!
Go!
Well, one of us finally learned how to run, but...
Don't worry.
I did all the hard work.
Okay, um...
Wait, cutscene?
Yeah.
Or did I just, like, die?
Did I...
Yeah, you died.
Yeah, I think you died.
Oh, it's us!
Oh, yeah, yeah.
I think we had to jump down.
Okay.
Yeah, it's good.
Okay, there's a level down here.
Do you mean to pull it?
Okay, I'm kidding.
How did you know I thought...
I was trying to get you to jump down.
Because that's how I died.
Oh!
Do you like bugs?
No, I'm actually...
I'm so...
I'm really afraid of ants.
Me too!
I just...
Do you know crane flies?
I'm terrified of crane flies.
What's the deal?
They're downy long legs that...
Oh, they're beetles.
Oh, look, that's not as bad.
That's not as bad.
I like beetles.
I like...
Listen.
Here you go.
Okay, I got it.
I got it.
This is the style.
I'm paying attention.
For real.
I'm shooting the floor.
Okay, get it.
Get it.
I've got it.
Yes, you have a good job.
Team kill.
All right, where's the next one?
Look at all them chickens.
All right, I believe this time.
I'm watching this.
First try.
Cut it off.
And then over here.
There you are.
I got one.
Nice.
Get them.
Go on there, chicken.
Pulled, and then the last one's over here.
I got you.
There you go.
And then there's a fourth one.
There's a fourth one.
Right, right, right.
Okay, nice.
Come on, bro.
This is actually a scary.
Oh, poor.
Run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run.
Wait, he has no face.
Oh, we're still in front now.
We gotta go find the box.
Oh, my God, we have to be behind the box.
We're gonna turn in a stone.
Yeah, he had no face.
Did you see that?
He was balding, too.
Do you think he was just malding?
Maybe he watches us.
Yeah.
Oh, I don't like that.
Oh, wait, that is so creepy.
Oh, it's a cutscene, which I thought it was real.
Oh, my God.
Oh, oh.
Oh, maybe it likes us.
Oh, okay.
It's the freaking Toy Story meme.
It was a dream.
We were in a coma.
The coma theory is real.
Oh, my God.
Wait, someone was having a good time.
I don't think they were.
I think that's actually the opposite.
Someone was having a good time.
Look at that.
You know what this is.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
He watched walkies.
He went walkies.
Someone's having too good.
Oh, it's time to learn how to tie a rope.
Well, I've been here before.
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
What?
Shoot that rope over there.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, shoot that rope.
All right, wrench time.
This way.
Let's come in the microwave.
I'm committed to the bit.
Yeah?
I'll get it done.
Watch this, boys.
Woo!
All right.
What is there up to?
You know, like, sometimes maybe there won't be fall damage
next time, you know?
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You gotta test it all out.
Gotta know which one has fall damage to, which one doesn't.
Oh.
Is that ashes?
I think that's just rock.
Oh.
Oh, my God.
Get your breath.
Just go for it, just go for it, and then you take it down.
You did it!
Yay!
Thank you.
You learned.
Thank you, thank you, I did it.
Oh, go, go, go, go.
Oh, you blocked me!
You blocked me!
You and your fat head blocked me!
What the fuck?
I think that's just skill difference, right there?
That's a skill issue?
I will, you're actually allowed to say that because you are
in every way of Effectively better than me at every video
game you could think of.
Yeah, so yes you could you can say that to me Yeah, no one
else can't chat.
Shut the fuck up.
You guys losing webkins.
Oh Baby man baby upsetting spaghetti Mostly the material in
wait.
I thought it was you sorry because you're you have a flat
head I don't my mom actually I'm scared you did you did
shoot the bus We need to stop talking because I'm like
locking in on our conversation I'm not looking at it.
I'll go and you go okay All right, all right.
I swear on my parents.
Now you go down.
Oh, I should have gone.
Don't get, I'm scared of Don't get, Don't get, I'm scared.
Don't get, I'm scared.
And now there was one.
Oh, that's the bad box.
I, okay, I'm not, I swear.
Don't worry, daddy's coming.
He's coming home.
He's gone to, yay.
I'm coming home.
I wish this happened in real life.
You coming home, not like getting like straight.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
dude i kind of wish this transport system was real i'd love
to get around i know i know right like it's be awesome i
feel like that's just so convenient you know like okay it's
like the old people elevator yeah yeah yeah i feel like it'd
be cheaper than uber too i know i just
you're smacking my butt okay let's move on let's cut that
out okay okay okay let's very serious let's play guys come
on it's very serious what does it look like when we hold
hands actually Oh, wait.
Wait, that's really cute.
Oh, wait, I can't drag you anywhere.
Wait, what's the purpose of holding your hand?
Being friends.
We've enjoyed the game so far.
I hope you guys have enjoyed more doki-dokie streams.
Because this is the last one.
Don't worry.
We're going to continue more next week.
Do you remember anything about the gameplay?
No.
Okay, all right.
The only thing I remember is that we were like jerking off.
Oh, dude, I'm doing that right now.
What do you mean?
Oh, here we go.
Oh, yeah.
All right, now we're locking in.
Now we're locked.
We were just acting before.
We were acting before.
No more joking.
Oh, that's a woman.
So you remember the...
Yeah, so when you see a woman, what do you do?
You just said this is my baby picture.
What the...
I don't like my...
Which one?
You told me you're my dad!
I think it's...
Why are we so dumb?
like no we're warming up we're warming up we're warming up
yeah yeah yeah we're warming up right now for the real
gameplay big all right chibi for her chibi for her where are
you maybe with with every new chibi their IQ increased by at
least one percent we can yeah see You come to this event
often?
They always do that.
A few moments later.
Alright.
You come to this event often?
Don't turn around!
Don't turn down!
You gotta learn to get better at rizzing, Chibi.
I have good rizz.
I have like the kind of rizz, like...
What's your success rate?
Motherfucker, I know you got arthritis.
Go faster.
Can you say it nicely, Chibi?
Remember what we taught you.
please please what please go
okay I know what the last word means you can't just speak a
different you can't just speak a different language thinking
you can get away with it GV I think I know what puta means
maybe when she's like not near oh oh she's freaking out oh
we should have waited
oh oh she's a spider a knob now to make it work shake it
yeah what happens to your ass shake it when i say i want a
woman that's all that's what i mean i don't think she even
has ass no more i'm really worried don't worry i'm scared
don't worry i'll look back where do we go oh scratch scratch
scratch yeah yeah yeah my core take a jump oh wait crouch oh
my god wait you can slide go go
It's faster!
That was actually so scary.
She's right behind us, isn't she?
We're skinny legends.
So Zenpix working.
It's a shame I'm going blind in 10 years, though.
Oh.
Oh, we gotta hide.
Hide.
There's no way.
I think she knew.
Yummy.
Candies.
Yeah.
Oh.
All right.
Yeah, see, I told you.
She's blind and old.
It looks like four skin.
If four skin is so good, where's the five skin?
Ask your mom.
She knows where it is.
Oh, my God.
Oh, I can get it.
Get it.
Slides.
I'm watching.
What the fuck?
Did you see that?
I need a referee.
Yes.
Yeah, I saw it.
up the jump yeah no no yeah on my screen yeah just like how
you couldn't make the okay oh it's a crusher you want to see
something she's getting mommy long legs yeah she is
hydraulic press oh this is so satisfying oh she got a
mammogram and then we can freeze dryer oh we can put her in
Yeah, we can keep my...
Hey, Wiki Grandma in our living room.
You can grab my hand.
All right.
Grab it.
Oh, there we go.
We did it.
You didn't even go in the mirror.
You did it.
Come along.
Firmly grasp it.
Oh?
Wait, you didn't go through.
Wait, I didn't go through.
Wait, I...
There's a lot of coming here.
Wait, am I not real?
Am I just a voice in your head?
Oh, this entire...
Oh, never mind.
I'm real, JK.
Us not having friends is a choice.
Exactly.
When I sleep until 4 p.m.
and don't speak to anyone except my parents, it's a choice.
Exactly.
I have so many people that reach out to me.
I definitely don't get excited when my phone buzzes, and it
turns out to be an Uber Eats notification every time.
Yeah.
That wasn't sad at all.